un nouveau pas vers le cancéropole avec
la mise en place officielle aujourd'hui
d'un comité scientifique international
c29 spécialistes aideront à définir
l'orientation des recherches sur le
cancer
le site rassemblera plus de 4000
personnes chercheurs privés ou publics
médecins et patients l'une des
stratégies de ce pro de ce projet est
d'aller du laboratoire vers le malade et
inversement du malade vers le
laboratoire l'europe l'état et les
collectivités locales ont aussi signé un
protocole de financement du cancéropole
hauteur de 50 millions d'euros
le début de la construction sur l'ancien
site azf est promis pour cet été avec
une mise en service en 2008